everybody welcome to part 7 of image
recognition and manipulation where we
left off we were bringing up the images
that we were going to consider and
talking about threshold and why we would
want to in showing you the images that
we're going to apply a threshold to we
did begin building our threshold and now
we're actually going to continue
building it and now what I think I'm
going to do is for now we'll just
comment this out with 3 little quotes
and at the end of it hidden up free
quotes and down here we're going to pass
through thresholds and the image that
we're going to want to do is going to be
I guess we'll start with aa ir3 so go
ahead and save that run it and you
should see the IMP are the the text for
the first pixel the second pixel is
basically we've got a 5 second timer on
this so these are the pixel valuations
right and this was that one that was
really hard to read so anyway I'm going
to stop it now now that we understand
where we are I'm going to go ahead and
we don't need to be printing out every
pixel and so what we're going to do is
we're going to average each of the
pixels in there so we're going to make
our averaging function so if you've
watched some of my other videos I use
this a lot but we're going to use is
reduce now we're going to make a lambda
X Y and it's going to be X plus y and
we're going to use each pix and we don't
really care about alpha so we're just
going to do two three we could go all
the way to four but then we might adjust
alpha I want to be dealing with alpha
right now maybe in another video anyway
so that's the beginning there and then
we want to divide by the length of each
pix two three
oops three or you just divide by three
really since it's only gonna have three
numbers in it but just to keep the
average function working out for us
anyway so that's that and then what we
want to do is go balance by learning
spell balance or a dot append and what
we want to append on a pen average num
to that balance array done next once
we've done that for every pixel right
that's going to average that the average
number in the pixels or how bright or
how dark is each our red green blue of
that pixel now and then we append that
to the balance all right now we want to
know it what is the average rate of that
so we'll say balance wow I did it again
balance equals reduce and then again and
in fact let's just copy paste this save
ourselves some time paste and now the
only thing we need change is eat and say
each pics two three we do balanced array
and balanced array so that will give us
an average of the balance then what
we're going to do is for each and we'll
do the same thing we did before for each
row in new array so we're going to start
changing up this newer rikes again like
an umpire is immutable you're not
allowed to really mess with it so we're
a mess with it this way uh for each row
a new array and then for each pics in
each row then we're going to say if the
average because again you don't want to
go by pixel by or you don't want to do
like red by green by blue you want to do
like a combination of them and that will
tell you because again right if if you
remember what I was explaining before
since it's an additive if you have like
the full red in the full green that will
make it even brighter than just a full
red right so if you have full red full
green or blue now I'm going to bright
white right and if you just have full
red green you've got something else and
so on and so
so we don't really want to know
per-pixel and like change like the red
the green the blue per pixel necessarily
the threshold some threshold in
operations you do it just really depends
what your goal is but in our case we're
just trying to make black and white
right so we don't really want to do that
so we're going to just say if reduce and
we'll take we'll take this function
right here this is exactly what we want
if pasted if that is greater than the
balance right so if this one is more
than the previous one what we want to do
is each pics or if it's more than not
previous one it's more than the average
right then that means this is one of our
lighter colors right so then we're let's
just convert everything
so we'll say each pig zero so like the
first part of that pixel right so the
red equals 255 and then we're just going
to copy and paste this a few more times
paste paste paste
so each pics and then one two three
obviously this is alpha will edit that
one as well so all of these values are
going to be 255 and that will make us a
nice pretty white else so if that's not
the case then what do we want to do well
we want to give everything a zero value
besides the Alpha so we'll just copy
this come down paste and then zero zero
zero and we leave alpha and then at the
end of this function what we want to do
is we could print it out right but
actually what we want to do is what's
called return and so that actually like
makes it act like it's like a math
function right so if you give one plus
one that's going to return something so
we want to return new array but it just
so happens this will end up modifying
the array anyways so it's not we don't
probably even really need to return
anything but we will so um
coming back down here now let's do
uncomment everything out hopefully we
didn't screw anything up and so we're
going to let's first let's look at it
one last time out of threshold so we'll
run this and we get this and we're going
to modify this image so you remember
what it looks like right now very hard
to look at and see but if we now call
threshold for ir3 and run it and
actually a theme ir3 let me let let's
look at this one yet so we want our
three anyway save that run that now that
we're running the threshold and we've
got balanced arrays not too fine let's
go back up here and look at it one last
time oh man I so badly want I call it
blance okay try again still remember
what the other one looked like do I did
it again how many blance arrays did I
doing here what a se reduce plants I did
it on all of them let's see here
balance why anybody tell me is
okay hopefully we'll see that again it's
pretty embarrassing anyway okay so now
you can see the it's been thresholded
right so we've got white white and black
and it looks nice and thresholded Thresh
held so now we could do it the same
thing we could run threshold for I r2 as
well let's do that and that and so now
we've got threshold threshold threshold
and now it's threshold this Centex image
and see how that looks so let's just
copy paste and we'll threshold
oops r4 save that run it and now we can
see what I was talking about as far as
blur is concerned like the syntax image
uh is a little like faded on the edges
like it's it's not like like perfect
right edges right got no threshold
almost and so anyway this one you can
see that you know the threshold will
held work pretty well but again let's
bring up just a regular image here you
can see how it kind of like it's not
like a solid here and it kind of fades
to white like it's not like a really
sharp picture so you bring up the other
one too so here it is so you can see
like at the tips the pixels slowly fade
to a white right so it just makes the
picture look a little softer to the
eyeballs and but anyway on a threshold
in operation that can kind of throw it
for a loop a little bit so you get
calling little jagged edges but in the
case of this image here you can see it's
actually got quite like 70 70 pixels so
it's like a 70 by a 70 so if you were
comparing this image to another one
these little chunks that are almost
missing when it make a huge difference
as far as comparing pattern to pattern
or image or a to image array that
wouldn't make this big of a difference
as it would here if these were like
really jagged here why not so anyways
that's the basics of our threshold and
so if you have two different colored
images and stuff you would want to use
threshold to basically make everything
on the same playing field you know so
you're dealing with the same exact
numbers when you're considering so
that's going to include tutorial number
as always thanks for watching thanks for
your support your subscriptions and
until next time